お残しはゆるしまへんでーー
食堂のおばちゃん
わかった！
ちゃんと食べるね
ふんっっ！！！
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです！
というものがあります
科学忍法！
光る
発光の術　バルーンスライム
スライムなんですけども
ストローを使うと
ぷくぷくっ　て
膨らむやつですね
で、光ると
もうガキどもが大喜び
女の子）うわぁ！！　光ってる！
男の子）なんで光るのぉ！！？？
ちょっと開けてみましょう
なにはともあれ、一回やってみることが
うぇ、、、
まってこれ、めんどくさいこれ？ひょっとして
えー　時間かかるのー
あーでもすぐできそうだぞぉ
えっとまずこれに入れていきます
うわぁ！うわぁ！
なんか
やばいエロいエロいエロい
とってもえｒ()
シェイクします
なるほど
脳震盪。
もう出していいんじゃないかな、だしてみます
あっ
わっすごい
おぅおぅおぅ
で、僕が今回目をつけてるのは
光るとかあんまりどうでもいいんですよ
これで風船を作りたいわけでございます
こうやっておいて
ストローおいて
で、包み込んで
で、勢いよく吹きかけると膨らむというわけでございます
スラ）ピュウピリュリュ～
おぉ～
スラ）パンッ
すごい！
これほんとに光るのかなぁ
はぁ！
という専用バルーンがあります
まとめてちんたらちんたらやっていても時間がかかってしまうので
これを作った過程をまとめてこの瓶で一気にやっちゃいます
ではいこう
はいっ！
なかなか驚異的な風船ができるんではないか
と、予測しているところではあるんですけれども
とりあえずじゃあ全部入れていきます！
はい、全部入りました
で、次はこの魔法水を全部入れていきます
コップに全部入れた後に
まとめてこうやって入れて振って完成していきます
よし
はい、というわけで全部入りましたぁ
はい、ということでこっからです
いきます！
やぁ～
うぅわ～
うぅわぁ！うわぁ！
まってそんなことより早く
シェイクしないと！
こうすると多分さっきと同じ定義だとどんどん固まっていくはずです
どぉんどぅぉん振っていきましょうぅ
うぅうぅ
うぅうぅうぅぅうぅう
うぁうへぼへぼへぼへぼ
あふぁあふぁあふぁあは
もう固まった！？
あっっ！
おっっ
スラ）パッシュコンッ
できたぁ！
きもぉ
まって最初に作ったやつをヒューチョン（？）させないと
スラ）ペンッッ
はいということで完成しました
このサイズでバルーンになる、そして光るというと
なかなかねぇ希少価値の高いスライムでございます
ちょっと一回光らせてみますか
光れ！スライム！
お～～
うぉうぉうぉうおお！！
はい、というわけで、巨大スライムできたわけなんですけども
ということで今回超巨大バルーンスライムを
膨らませるために準備したものはこちら！
スラ）ぺちょ
あぁ～い
ストローでやるより断然風の量が多いので
しっかりこいつを風船までたどり着くことができると僕は考えました
ではやっていきましょう
これできたらほんとやばいっすよ
もうサイズ感的にはほんと
まずはしっかり平べったくして、
ストローを置いて
折りたたむと、
両端をもって
スイッチを入れると膨らんでいきます
いきます！
あっ
あっ！
すごい！
あぁ
見えた見えた見えた
見えたぞぉ😎
重力の問題です
ふぁんっってなっちゃうんで
超でかくなりますよ
こっち向きでいきます
下向きでいきます
ふぉ！
スラ）ごめ
あぁ…
うぉおおぉ！
スラ）まじごめ